if you've not seen our great program
then there is something seriously wrong
with you but nevertheless we will fill
you in on all that happened because as
emperor i of course am privy to
everything that goes on in my court
huzzah he's not i arrived in russia with
love in my heart and alive with ideas
but that soon vanished when i met my
cool and idiotic husband i gifted you a
bear which you then shot
do you mean touche what is it not a
touch no i began planning a coup to
overthrow peter due to him being such a
terrible ruler quick to violence
deranged and perpetually drunk he's a
delicate son
others soon joined my cause made
a bureaucrat
and a drunk it was my greatest goal to
bring change to russia and i succeeded
this is science enjoy
sort of unfortunately my
well-strategized assault on peter did
not go exactly as planned and
i had to give up my lover leo to secure
russia's future although
leo was my heart ruling russia is my
destiny but my vision remained true yes
i discovered i am pregnant with peter's
child which was never part of the plan
hello paul
it's me daddy but it will not stop me
from taking the throne and building a
better russia
huzzah
[Music]